and the manager AJ Hinch of the Houston
Astros back here in the Rich Eisen show
I guess first easy question is how you
how are you doing
AJ you know we're doing fine you know I
think compared to a lot of the people in
Houston you know we're safe we're in
Tampa a plan plan a couple home games
it's hard to complain about anything
that we're going through compared to
what our city's going through you know
I've got family and friends with her
back and Houston doing a lot of good
things trying to help people we've been
lucky personally I've been lucky with my
family my wife and daughters are both
are they're all safe in our house our
house was not threatened by the by the
floodwaters pretty far north but a lot
of people aren't as lucky as me so I
know heart and prayers Ott's and prayers
and heartfelt feelings for a lot of
people that are that are in a lot worse
place than in houston astros well are
they remember are there any members of
your team or coaching staff or any staff
that's with you right now that does in
fact have somebody that is in distress
back home you know not in not in
life-threatening situations I mean we
have a lot of people in our organization
employees workers that work our games
that are that are that are losing their
houses and or that are have had to be
relocated we've got some of our players
families and coaches families with us
but but a lot are still back in Houston
but none are none are in
life-threatening situations we do have
some fear that a couple of our players
have lost their homes based on where
they live and and where the water damage
seems if we really don't know we haven't
been back since before we went to
Anaheim last weekend so we a lot of
unknowns a lot of you know I can't get
really in touch with any neighbors or
people or certainly can't send people
out to worry about how about our things
when they're trying to rescue people out
of waters right and then then you've got
obviously the task at hand that you need
to to focus on do you know where you're
playing the Mets series as you're
getting set for Game two with the
Rangers in in the home of the the Rays
agent don't I mean we think you know we
think we're going to find out today what
what's possible I know the two locations
are are either in Houston or here in
Tampa when we came here to Tampa for the
for the we had
potential play in six games here three
against the Rangers three against the
best any possibility of returning to
Houston is unknown at this point but I
think today sometime they're supposed to
get on a phone call and see what's
possible and see if we can go home or
see how we can accommodate our staff and
players you know we have a 12 day road
trip on the back end of this so if we
can get home we want to go home I think
a lot of its 101 now sure but what about
the state of Minute Maid Park again I'm
completely in the dark about this is
that is that something that is feasible
that that you could hold a game and
people can come and roads are open and
and I guess emergency services and first
responders can actually accommodate this
sort of thing you know I don't I don't
know I mean Reid Ryan is really the only
you know kind of high ranking member of
our front office who's back in Houston I
know you know Jeff Lunardi am was with
us in Anaheim were now in Tampa and so
it's you know we're relying a lot on the
on the people back in Houston to let us
know I know Minute Maid wasn't wasn't
flooded in there there it's safe and
it's you know it's in good it's in good
shape where it's at downtown but I've
you know to the to the extent that we
could could pull anything off I think
the officials that there's a lot of
things to worry about in Houston I think
our games probably the least of
anybody's concerned but and if we can go
home we will go home but I I just don't
know AJ Hinch Astros manager joining me
here on the show and and again as you
point out okay that we and I know and I
guess we need to keep on I guess shaping
our conversation through the prism of
how this is still technically the toy
department the sports world right
compared to other people's lives have
been turned upside down that said
emotions are very raw certainly in
between the Astros and the Rangers
because you guys are playing in Florida
and the Rangers were not up for swapping
home dates with you and your team how
did you receive that news and the rest
of your players receive that news AJ
that the Rangers tsunami were we were in
to paint the picture for we were in
Anaheim for a three-game series Friday
Saturday Sunday on Sunday we didn't
really know where
we were going we were we knew that there
was a possibility of a couple different
cities that we could go to to play a
neutral site we also knew that Dallas
was possible to go to Arlington and
either play two games there as a home
team or play the game there was a
visiting team so we went to Dallas and
as sort of a holding pattern to see what
was possible while all the conversations
were going on about playing there once
we were in the hotel we had an off day
on Monday we got a mass text to the base
I'd be ready to get on the bus at four
o'clock and that we were flying to Tampa
so I know MLB worked with the Rangers
and the Astros to try to find a you know
kind of common ground on what's what's
necessary I think the emotions that came
out of it were really just a release of
just what's going on in our world
especially from from our vantage point
where we played who we played how often
we played the miles we had to travel the
hotels we had to change like honestly if
you take a step back and look at it it
doesn't matter when you when you see
videos of personal friends who are who
are going into floodwaters to try to
stay friends so I think it's important
to keep an improper perspective but yes
there was a little bit of banter back
and forth about what's right or what's
wrong or where we should play but I
think everybody quickly shifted back to
what's important which is our you know
is your family safe or your friends safe
or your fan safe and let's let's
understand and this is bigger than the
game did you speak with Lance McCullers
because he was very vocal on Twitter
about greed never takes off days
apparently is what he tweeted once the
Rangers made their decision that they
didn't want to swap home dates of the
Astros I didn't talk to LAN he's on
rehab he's going to pitch in to LA
tonight so I texted back and forth of
them a little bit checking on his
family's wife's back in Houston by
herself so with all of our players I've
checked in to see you know the
whereabouts and how everybody's doing
you know Lance was very emotional about
it
I think all of us including myself we're
all misinformed we have no idea what
goes into these decisions that get to
the commissioner's office and and
ownerships involved in GM's are involved
and and you know the best interest of
the games involved and it's you know
again I'm proud that we would defend
ourselves I have no problem with Lance
you know being a motion
being protective of our own but I on the
same token again shifted back to not our
emotions and not our reactions but more
importantly how do what do we do to help
skew stand get back to being Houston and
then and when we can when we spend our
energy and our time and our money in
that way I think we'll feel better about
it master's manager AJ Hinch calling me
from calling the show from Tampa Florida
Game two of a three-game set with the
Rangers there so is there anybody that
you've reached out to I know you have a
background in in psychology from from
Stanford but is there any coach or
manager in any sport that's been through
this before
that you've reached out to and how to
manage the roster as well as be there
for the fans once you do return to a
hometown that's been through something
like this yeah I had a chance to really
reach out to too many we've been
juggling so much information and so many
guys here and and we have a half of our
families that are with us and we're
really trying to sort of huddle up
ourselves and do that I mean over time
and I've heard from a number of managers
in the big leagues I've heard from a few
college football coaches a person just
friends that have accumulated over my
years in the sport and I and I really do
appreciate that you know this you know I
guess you find out you know how many
people really do pay attention to what's
going on to you and when you know I get
out of a game last night and there's you
know 110 text messages from people just
just wanted to say hello and lend their
support so in sports out of sports
friends family the outpouring of care
and concern has been has been incredible
because whether you're in Houston or not
I think the images you know of the
ladies that are in the in the in the
retirement home knitting while they're
in chest-high waters or the mant the man
carrying a kid across the street those
are those who lost you forever so what
was it like playing in front of 4,000
fans out of the home state for
technically a home game what the heck
was that like last night yeah I know it
was bizarre because the we're playing
the Rangers you know I was I was joking
before if you were watching baseball for
the first time and you saw two texas
teams playing in florida the home team
wearing gray uniforms and in the
visiting Clubhouse and the the visiting
team wearing white uniforms in the home
clubhouse
we really wouldn't have recruited you to
watch our sport much we didn't thought
we were crazy so it was you know the
fans that came out they were great I
know they donated money and time and you
know the Tampa Bay Rays have been
fantastic to open up his building for us
and they're donating all the proceeds
and it's you know everyone's everyone's
all hands on deck trying to make things
better for people but it was you know a
little different than a spring training
game because you're at a different site
but it it definitely was where our fans
were good they were they were into it
there were chants in the stands and
people that were having a good time it
was a it was a relaxed environment the
game turned south for us we got beat up
a little bit but the you know the the
atmosphere was as positive as it could
be given the circumstance
yeah and Carlos Correia just I guess
talked about a little baseball he's
coming back Friday wherever you are
going to be playing is that is that
correct you're expected think that's a
little premature I think it's going to
be over the weekend in the best case
scenario but he's traveling because I
think he's traveling to double-a he's
gonna join our double-a team for a
couple games which we'll push it back
into the weekend but he's getting better
it'll be a big boost for us when he gets
here just to have one of our
centerpieces back in the middle of the
order and back playing shortstop you
know I you know whether it's because
these have been out or just because of
the rigors of the schedule we've been
just okay since he left he's a big
presence on our team he's a big presence
in our lineup it's hard to bestowed that
kind of responsibility on a 22 year old
but he can handle he's one of the best
players in baseball so we'll only get
him back it'll be yeah last one for you
if you did have you seen what JJ what's
been up to oh man have you seen that
raising money it's awesome
I mean he's you know he along with you
know James Harden of the Rockets Jose
Altuve on our team probably the three
biggest stars in our city and they're
all stepping up in some capacity JJ's
obviously at the front of it with with
his with his raising money I mean he
started out just wanting a couple
hundred thousand dollars which is a lot
of money and it's turned into he's close
to five or six million now so it it
shows the support that he has it also
she approached shows how you can bring
people together and try to fund what's
going to be a long recovery he's around
our team a lot I loved
he's a big fan of the Astros were big
fans of his and and but to watch him
step up like you know within hours of
this happening you know a big kudos to
him and had to AJ thanks for calling in
under these circumstances obviously and
good luck I'd love to keep in touch with
you throughout the month of September
and and whatever you're doing for your
team and for your city we are we're
behind you the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that please download our app there's
lots of fun things there other than just
more of the videos you just saw you can
call us from the app you can email us
from the app just download it trust me
you'll enjoy